aiuta
bentornati stone il dottor es
a grandissima richiesta oggi faremo il
video green i due nella vita reale
avete chiesto in tantissimi di fare il
nuovo gioco credi 2 nel realtà e se
questo video raggiunge i 45mila fials e
allora faremo anche trova di ingredienti
slime nascosti dalle grandi 2
praticamente ci sarà sia granny che il
nonno quindi è il doppio più difficile
quindi mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi
piace
iniziamo questa avventura assieme
ovviamente c'è sempre il mio aiutante
che sta andando su di fare tutto
qual è l'obiettivo di questo gioco
dobbiamo scappare dalla casa dei gremi e
del nonno xvi a quanto pare treni si è
fidanzata
non so chi potrebbe fidanzarsi con
granny ma lo scopriremo tra poco dovrà
riuscire a scappare senza essere beccata
per cinque volte perché o cinque giorni
di tempo come gli altri premi
siete pronti mettetevi comodi prendete i
pop corn iniziamo subito a zona
guardate un po dove solo sono una specie
di stanze
cola una sorta di corridoio
qui c'è un bagno un mobiletto faccia
paura che spunti credi o il nonno
all'improvviso berlino mi devi aiutare
mi devi dire se senti che g si avvicina
mi devi aiutare ok proviamo uscire dalla
porta
no è chiusa iniziamo con i allora
suppongo che devo cercare una chiave in
questa stanzetta piccola così un mobile
però magari può essere qua dentro
sarebbe troppo facile
l'energia non pensavo sarebbe stato così
semplice trovare la chiave da trino
sei contento che abbiamo già trovato la
chiave si è anche merli no non si mangia
la chiave manilow ma insomma ok
apriamo la porta vediamo prestazione
speriamo di non ritrovarci granny o il
non so vediamo
ok siamo in un'altra stanza e massimo
delle scale so se esplorare questa zona
o scendere le scale ma qualcosa mi dice
che c'è qualcosa di strano qua dentro
per chi no
berlino ma pensi che ovviamente ora
dobbiamo iniziare a fare molto silenzio
di chi abbiamo
queste sono le strade su un pò in cui
davanti non so se provare a fare
scendere prima a berlino dopo una
gravidanza per nissim a berlino 6 quota
problema scendere le scale questa dice
accendendo stai controllata se c'è
qualcuno
per la fim facilmente imprese che fosse
anch'essi ok ci tiene a pian piano
bravissimo nel minuto visto almeno sei
una luce che questi prese dai berlino
scendendo
si mettesse un sito per rumore
salendo hai visto qualcosa non mi sembra
che ci sia gente queste ore pare che
qualcosa ma io devo scendere la stupra
non c'è niente
se vuoi far tacere io sono qua
[Musica]
scusa
o no il nonno mi ha preso subito ma
avete visto quanto era brutto erano
molto inquietante forse anche più di
garelli scrivete nei commenti se secondo
voi è inquietante il nonno o g comunque
per fortuna non c'era anche i premi sono
momenti nella stanzetta andiamo
scendiamo le scale questa volta stiamo
al tenni per la corda e cioè aperta la
porta che strano forse qualcuno è
passato a 5 2 marino no mattino ha
rimosso e ciò con il nonno devo andare a
recuperarlo subito perché se agende da
sola cosa andiamo subito a chi non lo
prendo un asino
[Musica]
e una contestuale rubando
come
per noi
[Musica]
berlino o no nuovamente questa volta mi
ha preso granny ma è ancora più
difficile g 2
torniamo però questa volta era colpa di
berlino non capisco perché merlino si
butta sempre addosso al grammy e io devo
sempre stampato in volto e mutu
ceniamo uno come inter e scale e
entriamo in quella stanza in cui sarà g
sono sicura che la chiave lì da qualche
parte
perché no pino
vediamo chi è favorito ma non possiamo
fare qua dai sei di marino andiamo
[Musica]
berlino rivelino vediamo perché non mi
ascolti
vieni marino e g
e a riguardo così quindi dire che c'è
qualche pericolo fantino siano i nonno
che cambino
oddio come faccio devo scappare non
posso assolutamente entrare dentro
questa stanza ma aspettate 1 m
non mi hanno ancora visto che strano
guardate in non ho una chiave appesa
riuscita a vederla forse quella è la
chiave per uscire però non so quale la
porta per uscire per meglio che scappo
adesso si aggreghi
il nonno quasi alla stanza da letto non
penso che ci sia nessuna chiave perché
il piace l'ho vista addosso al nord
quindi non penso proprio che non ci sia
qualcosa
[Musica]
fatevi fregare ancora ma non ci casco
quindi la reddito ma ci sono meno e
storico raskar chissà se devo scendere
le scale cosa devo fare
quasi una porta ma non pensi a questa
sarebbe stata troppo facile quindi forse
bocciando in estate lo spende rino non
bd e lì è rimasto lì lo avete sentito
[Musica]
merlino
io già non viene chiamata qua no merlino
berlina ecco di pini attent una trappola
pini velino
[Musica]
ma perché non riesco tutti berlino
quando la voglio
questo corso si è aperta
vediamo però sembra che questa volta
porti fuori porta a porta
forse la chiave per questa porta o forse
qualche altra porta alla fine di queste
scale
io spero che altra questa così al
tramonto se credi merlini 31 pt devi
fare mori mi chiamo abbastanza se ci
sono ancora tutte e due
[Musica]
eccola c'è il mondo devo riuscire a
prendere la chiave è venuta un'idea non
posso arriva quasi dal letto forse
[Musica]
spostato kenya ok
centravanti siamo qua per nasconderci
dietro anno pazzi
[Musica]
si no
ok ora dobbiamo riuscire a tirare spero
che sarà abbastanza per stordirlo no
lascia berlino nome fino devo tirarmi
qualcosa aiuta ieri questo predicato
prendi neanche corretto forse ci sono il
solido prendo questo e prende est io mi
sono imbattuta labour
prendi questa è prenderlo ragazzi ha
funzionato
prendi questo questo è l'ultimo o no
berlino che fai forteight la ciao
ragazzi ha funzionato ora devo scendere
subito provare a prendere la chiama
prima che si risvegli prendiamoci perché
oggi
spegnere presto brutto sentiamo ok e
rino proviamo noi negata devo riuscire
io mi pare persone devo riuscire a
sfidarla l'edizione vediamo successo
come dice da qualche parte
[Musica]
ecco le chiavi piedi possono essere
pericoli per questo portarlo con me
berlino si chiama quello da crimi fuori
abbiamo htc abbia mostrato stiliti
abbiamo salvato tutti non puoi fare
niente da qua
vuoi fare niente perchè abbiamo vinto
evviva ce l'abbiamo fatta non so perché
ho questo sticcio in mano ma perché
merlina se lo vuole mangiare e vera
abbiamo vinto la challenge
se volete vedere una seconda parte
lasciate un bel mi piace e nella
prossima parte dovremo trovare gli
ingredienti slime nascosti dal nonno e
da cremi mi raccomando st raggiunge il
45 mila mi piace faremo la seconda parte
e ora vi lascio qua 4 castellina su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao
[Musica]